[Musik]
[Applaus]
stellvertretend die selbst der
ehrengäste soldatinnen und soldaten der
stellungskrieg
es ist nur topscorer eine große freude
sie heute bataillonskommandant zur
angelobung der etwas anderen art
begrüßen zu dürfen
sehen sie diesen tag als ihren festtag
als einen bewegenden momente während
ihrer zeit beim österreichischen
bundesheer sie werden auch in zukunft
gerne an diesem tag zurückblicken
heute werden sie das treuegelöbnis
spüren
unter normalen umständen weil das im
zuge eines öffentlichen festaktes
entzogen worden
inmitten von hunderten gästen ihren
familien und bekannten ihren freundinnen
und freunden
aufgrund der gesamtheitlichen lage ist
das jedoch nicht in dieser form möglich
nur wenigen auserwählten ist es
gestattet an diesem festakt teilzunehmen
denken sie an werte die es zu bewahren
gilt
das betrifft jeden von ihnen
es sind werte in ihrer familie werte in
der gesellschaft
denken sie aber auch an militärische
pflichterfüllung und loyalität
ich bin sicher dass sie ihre ausbildung
zum soldaten ernst nehmen und wir uns
auf sie verlassen können
dix sieht kein lippenbekenntnis ab
sondern bekennen sie sich ohne wenn und
aber und in aller deutlichkeit zu ihrem
heimatland der republik
juli militär geistlichkeit gesetzt
daherkommt als komponente gesetzt daher
militärkapelle investor soldaten aller
dienstgrade aber freuen gesetzte
regionen des entwicklungstools erwähnt
2020 selbsthilfe ist der leitspruch des
österreichischen bundesheeres um als
bundesheer wirksame schutz und hilfe
leisten zu können bedarf es nicht mehr
zeitgemäßen ausrüstung sollen neben
anwendungs man die ihre dienstleistung
gleichem einheit als der dienstleistung
der soldat unserer bevölkerung zur
verfügung stellen für diese botschaft
möchte ich euch gesetztere kunden ganz
herzlich danke sagen ihr werdet in kürze
informelle und herrlich erfahren das
treuegelöbnis zur republik österreich
abtreten ergebnis mit allen kräften und
im notfall auch mit der waffe die
sicherheit unserer großeltern
einzutreten
das bedürfnis nach sicherheit ist ein
grundbedürfnis jedes menschen
aber auch jeder gemeinschaft von der
familie bis hin zum start
es ist die elementare voraussetzung für
eine positive entwicklung hier
als bürger der republik österreich haben
das privileg in einem umfeld
aufgewachsen zu sein
das vom militärischen krisen in den
letzten jahrzehnten verschwunden drin
ist
wobei es nicht angebracht ist sich
deswegen zurückzulehnen und elementare
sicherheitsregeln zu den nachlässigen
den riesen kommen meist überraschend und
ohne vorwarnung und wer nicht gerüstet
ist und soll gesagt hat keinen schaden
nehmen
das bundesheer ist ein teil dieser chris
weigl und ein unverzichtbarer
bestandteil der österreichischen
umfassenden landesverteidigung und somit
der gesamten staatlichen krisenfürsorge
dies hat man gerade in der aktuellen
kampagne ganz verdankt erleben können
selten wird deshalb die alles haben
tausende soldaten die gesundheits- und
sichert behörden bei dem funktion danke
maßnahmen gegen das unkontrollierte
ausbreiten dieser neuartigen weltweit
verbreiteten kein geld unterstützen
ziemlich sicher irgendwo auch weil ich
verhindern in den kommenden tagen wochen
oder monate in irgendeiner dass man im
namen der unterstützung unserer
gesundheitsbehörden eingesetzt werden
als soldaten die in einem stadion im
rücken werden sie jedoch im bereich der
logistik und der
reicht es mit drittel seines wechsels
sei es als kraftfahrer mechaniker ex
soldat oder im bereich der truppenküche
sie lösten dabei einen wichtigen beitrag
zur sicherstellung der
einsatzbereitschaft des österreichischen
bundesheeres
seit kurzem gibt es die möglichkeit
einer gut bezahlten quasi die
verlängerung ihres sechsmonatigen
wehrdienstes der bataillonskommandant
hat das einmal gesprochen
der moment sind an die 1000 soldaten zur
sicherung der österreichischen ost und
süd grenze den über illegale anders
eingesetzt
ich möchte daher bewusst auch den anlass
ihrer einstellung nutzen und sie
ermuntern und entladen eine oder auch
mehrere monaten unmittelbar im anschluss
an ihren grundwehrdienst als miliz
soldat an diesen grenzen
sicherungseinsatz teilzunehmen
das heißt der kunde sehen sie ihren
grundwehrdienst leben ihren dienst an
der allgemeinheit auch als einen ersten
schritt zum erwachsenwerden und zur
persönlichen reife legen sie den kontakt
mit ihren kameras leben sie die
sprichwörtliche militärische
kameradschaft nehmen sie auch das
verstärkte körperliche training das sie
in den kommenden monaten erfahren werden
mitte märz will das leben nach dem
grundwehrdienst und erhalten sie so ihre
gesteigerte wenn es als lebenslange
gesundheitswesen abschließend 30
gesetzte kunden einen erfolgreichen und
unfall seines wehrdienstes fühle
er hat die erlebnisse und zwei soldaten
ums leben
das heißt dass im bundesheer es wird
unsere heimat
[Musik]
so
die gruppe sprechen sie mir nach ich
genommen
mein vater ist ob sein volk zu schützen
unser volk zu schießen und mit der waffe
zog verteidiger verteidiger
ich denke werde ich sein unter
gesetzmäßige behörde treue und gehorsam
es zulässt dass gross anzulasten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten war der
vorgesetzte und trägt und genau zu
befolgen und die auch zu befolgen und
mit allen meinen kräften der republik
österreich zufrieden